you want to start the the podcast by
bashing netflix no yeah that was a weird
why are you not against that well i mean
yeah the the the new netflix special is
about to drop but no what we were
talking about oh sorry sorry you want to
promote the new special no no no i love
what you're saying i don't they don't
they don't mind you or something they
don't mind talking about it but you were
saying something about how they weren't
[ __ ] with you or something like that
yeah they weren't [ __ ] with a lot of
us right right yeah but then you were
like yo you need to suck this dick okay
i don't know
i don't i don't think that's and this is
when i get cancer
i do the hashtag
i came in here
like i go i was on my stream i was like
about to go with andrew schultz hashtag
and i left it blank and i i decided i'll
fill the blank when i leave but i got
the doll yeah it's been fun yeah
he's tired now
okay no no tell this story no it's a
great story like they just didn't want
to
they didn't want to invest in uh the
special yeah so when when i when i found
out that they were doing originals
instead of just
leasing or whatever it is that they do
right now they're at least licensing and
like whatever so whatever they were
doing a little bit you know
yeah but back then like 2016 they were
you know they were just getting stuff
from comedy central and posting it on
their on their platform and then and
then when they said they were doing
original content i was like well
this hour is hot you got to see my hour
man like and and they wouldn't even look
right i was like wait what
and schultz i was crushing man yeah like
i was cr i was putting up numbers yeah
like every improv i was doing like 20
shows in a row like anywhere in the
country it was just like i can go to
chicago do three weeks of straight
improvs and then go to [ __ ] and then go
to i can do three i can do la brea i can
do brea
ontario
irvine within the same month and do 21
shows 24 shows like 20 shows all in the
same months
but yet they didn't want to really
understand it they weren't they were
like they and they would have like this
they would have like an excuse but i
didn't understand i was like wait what
what is your excuse they wouldn't say it
directly but they were just
i think i understood what was it i don't
want to say
but i think you know
now you can definitely say it yeah yeah
because the new the the new uh the new
crew there is amazing they're wonderful
but like uh all right
[Laughter]
and then we were just like all right
screw it like we offered eight times
dude there was this one time i said i
will fly you to san francisco because it
was a huge show it was a huge show
i was doing like 20 shows at the cobbs
at cobb's comedy club i was like i will
fly you guys in on a private i'm not
trying to even brag like honestly i go i
will fly you guys in on a private jet
yeah right after work just come to san
francisco i'll get a driver to drive you
and then i'll drive you back to the jet
and you'll be in bed tonight
and they still turned it down like i was
trying so hard to get them to come and
this is before netflix was like the
behemoth yeah everything this is when
they were saying that they were gonna
get like all these comebacks like chris
is gonna write and yeah a new special
one dave's coming back and everyone's
coming back you know this year this is
why we still called specials hbo
specialists yes yes right so that yes
and then so i wanted to be in that
roster yeah i was like i deserve to be
in that roster [ __ ] yeah so then uh
and then uh they turned it down i was
like what and then all of a sudden they
gave a call and they were like uh
yeah you know we're just gonna go ahead
and pass
and i'm like what before even seeing it
didn't even see it like you didn't even
see it why even why anybody is what do
you think it was
i don't know man i don't know what do
you just think you might have somebody
let's just say
it was too specific
and to me and to me racially specific
is just a uh
a very fancy word for
we're racist
[Laughter]
whoever whoever is in in in
at that time or whoever was in that
position because to me i'm like what
does that mean specific
i have a specific story
what are you saying yeah i have a
specific voice i'm american yeah i live
in america yeah and my mother's american
and she lives in america in fact she's
lived here longer than all of us in here
yeah so she's really american yeah yeah
she has an accent
but so does jeff fox really yeah yeah so
what is specific i don't get it other
than we don't want to hear your mom's
voice on tv yeah
this is what i always say like whenever
i hear someone say something really sly
or you know like oh he's doing that
thing about his mom again it's like okay
well my mom's been living here since
1969.
she works her ass off pays taxes
she goes home and watches tv
and i always talk about there's a lot of
nurses in filipinos yeah in the filipino
community we i have a lot of nurses in
my family yeah
and they go to work at a hospital 14
hours a day and then when they come home
they turn on the tv and they watch a tv
show about a hospital
and not one filipino nurse is on that
show oh
then you go watch a movie
and you see a hospital scene just an
emergency room scene yeah let's just say
that we're not even one filipino nurse
is running across the hallway
and to me
how how do you think that person feels
other than invisible
you don't think she feels the hospital
is more safe
yeah
but now yeah that's funny but how
invisible do you think she feels to live
in this country and to feel like oh so
then not only do you not want to hear my
voice but on tv i don't even [ __ ]
exist
so thank you but i've been here for 59
years so thank you for that oh and my
son's going to do one story about me and
you don't want to hear it because it's
too specific
so i'm the only voice i'm the only voice
and like when people go oh uh
oh that he's just doing that filipino
accent [ __ ] i'm not doing a
filipino accent i'm doing the best
impersonation of my mother
i can give a [ __ ] about any other
person's story but the weird thing is
that like your mother's the white one
that was the thing that was weird
because most people don't know this
about your dad is filipino
if you look at the comedy through that
lens you're the most edgy comedian i've
ever seen actually i don't know if you
know this but my mom is a white woman
from little manila in queens yes yes yes
i know this
dad who is a mailman yup filipino male
man yes yeah and this is a story i've
been pitching to abc and they won't buy
it it's [ __ ] up it's because your mom
will do the accent she learned tagalog
or whatever it's called
how do you want to how do you want to
[ __ ] up my tagalog
tagalog it's
[Laughter]
she says it like you so uh birds with a
feather
you know like people say it yeah
you pronounce it so specifically
you gotta bring your white mom on stage
like i've never showed my mom but
finally the biggest show you're doing
and she went like this joseph
dude in manila
i just count my money go [ __ ] y'all
i won again does your mom not want to be
in the public eye does she not want to
because it'd be ironic if you if she
wants to be invisible and your whole
career is built on you're giving her
visibility no she she she loves it man
she loves what's happening right now
but um but it sucks i'm not gonna lie it
sucks and like and people don't
understand how hard that was like people
go oh joe blew up because the netflix
special i'm like i shot that [ __ ] yeah
and you know here's another thing that
no one knows is uh also it takes a long
time to blow up overnight bro yeah yeah
oh here's the story yeah yeah you were
the first comic i ever saw in la 2007
wow this is crazy i think finesse
mitchell was headlining super funny but
you and tiffany haddish were both the
future comics and i remember thinking
laughter in 2007 i just moved to la i
remember thinking tiffany had this star
quality and like my boy and i were like
yo she's a star and then i remember
watching you and i was dying [ __ ]
laughing yeah i don't to this day i
don't know if you were high or not
but i was [ __ ] and i remember
thinking this guy is so free on stage i
had i
hadn't really started comedy but i was
like that's what i want the freedom he
has on stage the jokes you were doing
was telling stories about your mom were
so good but 15 years i've remembered
that and then you know as you're
building i don't realize what's going on
i'm like yo i would i swear to god i'd
be like what happened to that guy jokoy
so [ __ ] funny then i saw the comedy
central special then i saw the netflix
then i'm seeing arenas and it was like
yo man that guy [ __ ] grinded his way
up and deserved it and it's so cool to
see thank you man of course man i
remember seeing you
that night and thinking the same thing
about your eyes
i was like how is he so
brown and his eyes aren't yeah and maybe
that's why i was
how did did he deliver food or something
yeah how did he no he just got me with
his eyes kind of like right now yeah
you're just lost look at his goddamn
eyes yeah they're very nice yeah i was
there ordering water because i couldn't
afford even diet coke oh yeah yeah
would lock everybody down yeah okay so
then you go and you crush and you become
a superstar well how do you get it onto
netflix no so here's here's another
thing andrew that no one knows is uh two
days before i was shooting
they call my manager and go hey we heard
joe coy shooting his special we just
want you to know that we're really not
interested in that special
unnecessary that's a true story
unnecessary something happened with the
philippines and the person who was the
head of netflix yeah that's the head uh
the head of the netherlands he's
filipino
that's why really that's why that's what
he knows how annoying filipino people
are yeah and he's like nobody wants to
hear from these people this is too much
nobody's gonna like this there's no way
this is gonna work because he knows them
at their core yeah yeah well he is the
core he's the core he's a filipino he's
really filipino no andrew
his mom is white what are we doing
sounds like it you're [ __ ] up
everyone's name you're a china man
[Laughter]
you've been lying the whole time you've
been lying the whole time i had to flip
it i had to flip it i felt
my way mom's an immigrant
oh
you've got to actually give a [ __ ] about
yourself
how's your mom your mother
he's a singer
your mom
your mom's an army immigrant
okay no she's a scottish woman
yeah and i was told that it was too
specific as well really yeah
you're full of [ __ ] i was i was told
that my whole family was told that what
they were doing was too specific and
then they were taken over by the uh the
brits
and then uh do you know where the queen
ended up dying
where
scotland
joke's on you [ __ ]
right yeah
i guess you got the final word that's it
payback
queen
queen
okay okay so she died she went like this
it's too
specific specific [ __ ] kick the can
okay so then you find you you go two
days before they go we don't want your
[ __ ] yeah okay we shot it anyway and ted
called you specific like himself no no
ted ted no ted's ted call me
specifically yeah no we shot it we cut
it and then uh
and then like
we we submitted it and like literally
like
maybe an hour later they go we want it
they knew wow yeah they knew wow yeah
yeah
what made you say [ __ ] it i'm gonna film
it anyway because i knew it was good you
knew it was that good and i knew i was
good and you it and your intention if
they didn't buy it you would just put it
out yourself bro you know i i you know
you shoot two that's what some people
have to do when no one wants their
specialist yeah yeah we just had to put
it on youtube and see what happens yeah
it's also a great option yeah it's
really great yeah i mean it's some
people innovate and some people follow
that model yeah it is it works out
you know
it works out
it works out man you know what i mean
it's [ __ ] beautiful in here
it's beautiful in here it's pretty good
[Laughter]
you're so dumb okay no but go so what
happens uh we shoot it and uh when they
ask for it do you [ __ ] double the
price yeah
how do you feel about the little girl i
find out oh man i cried i'm not gonna
lie i mean because it was a year process
it was like
2015
was when we found out that they were
doing originals 2017 so they're going to
shoot 2016. yeah they turned me down in
2015. it was like 2016 was just me you
know getting the money
getting the directors finding the venue
like it was just a whole year of me just
mapping this out and my team you know my
manager my promoters and yeah it was a
lot it was a lot of stress but we were
like we got to do it and and i didn't
care like if they didn't buy it i was
gonna i would literally make
dvds if i had to even though they didn't
sell them i was gonna sell it out of the
back of my car yeah you were hungry yeah
but you also knew that the people wanted
that's the thing about like being on the
road when you sell out shows it's proof
of concept yeah like that's why when
they say algorithm i don't get it i'm
like what algorithm are you talking
about yeah the one where people leave
their house i don't understand that i'll
go with them
i don't know what algorithm what are you
talking about because i got i got four
forums sold out i got two honda centers
sold out
i got two
[ __ ] i got two chase centers sold out
during the playoffs
it's golden state joe coy golden state
joe coy
and i got i got key i got i got climate
pledge arena sold out six months to
advance then i'm terrible homodome
sold out yeah stockton and playing the
kings two times two two kings like i'm
all up and down then madison square
i no i'm just like i just want to know
what your algorithm is yeah yeah
i want to know what your demo is and i
want to know what specifically you're
talking about how much you get paid for
the last so rich how much you get paid
for the last question this one from
netflix how much you get oh not much not
much come on bro no not much 10 million
no i'm not good at 20 20 million no not
much at all not much for him now it's
high yeah yeah not much for you yeah no
not much at all
25.
where's my which one's my camera cause
they're
[Laughter]
okay so somewhere between 20.
but it's 20. it's not it's not a lot of
money you deserve 20. not a lot of money
you just if you're selling well thank
you thank you i'm just saying they
deserve it
i appreciate that okay 10 000 seats on a
wednesday in the philippines like it's
not something like something like they
have nothing to do but
i'm just saying ten thousand i'm not
bragging but i think i think after 33
years i should be able to say these
things damn what were the seats made out
of even yeah well out of my knife bring
your own
10 000 seats in the philippines as much
as about 150 seats in the
u.s he sold an improv on a tuesday yeah
i i didn't hear anything you said
because your eyes
so you might not want to talk this whole
[ __ ] show
because i'm not going to listen to
anything all right just smile and keep
your eyes good and he's freshly single
right
[Laughter]
were you guys really in a relationship
be honest yeah now now this that doesn't
seem like a yes it doesn't seem like it
this is fun to even show us that play
with this just that type of conversation
i am your white mother right now
yeah
how do you know how to play with that
he's going through a breakup why are you
doing this
what do you want to do with that did we
pretend to laugh and believe that
question yes then we'll all laugh at
that okay yeah i deny our relationship
with it no i yeah i mean
you know it's a breakup whatever we're
still friends but
you know are you heartbroken no no not
at all we you know the way the way it
happened the way it happened at the
beginning
no cause it's uh you know it's a breakup
bro it's like whatever crazy but i
really don't want to talk about it okay
it's a breakup fair enough i don't want
to make you feel uncomfortable here no
no but you did you ever hear people go
like are they really yeah but i i always
touch people are stupid yeah yeah yeah
yeah
also they're also ugly yeah yeah and i
also thought anyone who thinks like
there's an insecure yes
piece of [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] yeah yeah but
no one thinks like that i mean nobody in
this room
am i right guys
okay now here's the thing we're all
adults here we're not
hello no that's a lot 14